die fdp-fraktionsvorsitzende und
oppositionsführerin all dies weil hat
mit ihrer rede im bundestag am mittwoch
für empörung gesorgt
in der generaldebatte war weil der
bundesregierung vor mit einer ihrer
ansicht nach ungezügelten einwanderung
vor allem von muslimen den wohlstand zu
gefährden sogar die ausschüttung der
einwohnerzahl durch zugewanderte
straftäter mit mehrfachen identitäten
scheint sie überhaupt gar nicht zu
stören doch ich kann ihnen sagen in
burkas kopftuchmädchen und alimentierte
messer männer und sonstige taugenichts
werden uns in deutschland das
wirtschaftswachstum vor allem den
sozialstaat nicht sicher wer soll in
zukunft für die renten aufkommen wer
zahlt denn ihre staatlichen pension auch
ihre hoheit schreihals ihre
eingewanderten deutsch-türke etwas haben
sie ja wohl nicht im ernst
vertreter aller anderen
bundestagsparteien reagierten mit lauten
zwischenrufen und buhten weidl aus
bundestagspräsident wolfgang schäuble
weiter
[Musik]
sie haben in ihrer rede die formulierung
unter anderem kopftuchmädchen und
sonstige taugenichts sie gebraucht damit
diskriminieren sie alle frauen die ein
kopftuch tragen dafür so wie sie zur
ordnung
unionsfraktionschef volker kauder von
der cdu kritisierte weiden schafe ihre
aussagen und wenn es dann in diesem haus
kolleginnen und kollegen gibt die das
christliche abendland retten wollen und
dann über andere menschen so sprechen
wie sie es gemacht haben vor weil hat
dies mit christliche menschenbild nichts
zu tun
neuer hat es damit zu tun kauder warf
der afg insgesamt vor sie sei zwar
großmaul ich im austeilen dafür aber
schwach im einstecken
[Applaus]